welcome to the afternoon session of this
workshop we have film talks scheduled
for this afternoon and they'll be a
break tough after the second the end of
the second talk the first off is by Duma
diary from a local university will tell
us about quantitative algebraic
reasoning thank you okay so I'm grateful
to Frank because with his talk he
actually prepare my tokens I don't have
to say so much about this matrix I can
jump jump directly into them and I'm
gonna start by taking actually some of
his his arguments there he mentioned
this matrix and he said that what we
expect from this matrix is that if they
report zero between two systems I'm
expecting the systems to be by similar
and that was where the description ends
and there are also of course many other
matrix but the one that Frank presented
that is doing that so the motivation of
this work from the beginning which was
some years ago was to try to understand
if we have some arguments for believing
that exists the kind of canonic metric
once you give me the type of system so
because if you think a bit if you give
me the type of system the factor that
represent your your behavior then the
concept of by simulation for instance
once you decide that it must be defined
as the span or as a correspond and once
we take that decision it comes for free
the concept of eyes musn't it's nothing
it's not something that you are adding
to the toys it's coming from from the
description of the system so then the
question is if I'm speaking about
probabilistic systems do I have such a
thing and not only probabilistic in fact
in this talk all quantitative systems
can be found so initially I started
thinking about this with Prakash some
years back and trying to identify such
conditions we arrived to prove some kind
of stone duality for maîtrise the
Markov processes together also with the
help of Dexter cousin and there we
succeed to identify a kind of sufficient
condition for such a metric to be good
so what does it mean to be good since we
don't we cannot really say without
strong philosophical assumptions that
the universe behaved probabilistically
we have to accept that probabilistic
systems are nothing else but
approximations so if suppose that I have
an infinite better and better
approximation of a system I have such a
chain if I have such a metric and if I
claim that this metric is behaving
properly I'm expecting to prove in the
topology induced by this metric that
such a better and better approximation
converges in fact to that limit so now
the question is what would be the
condition on such a metric to guarantee
this kind of convergence so as I said in
that work about Valley to succeed to
identify some conditions for such maps
for some metrics to behave like this
topologically nice but here the question
took went to - to the next step so we
are still looking to see if we can
somehow say that some metrics are
canonical so we took another starting
point which was the concept of Monat so
we know from moji that in general the
concept of computations can be seen as
derived from monads and then plot can
empower later show that you can speak
about monads in terms of algebraic
effects so that's nice but all these
monads are in general along the category
of sets what about the monads on the
category of metric spaces because this
is what we have
so well in this approach if you look
from a categorical point of view easily
you move from one a school of eateries
in the work of protein on power and if
you go to to look to the monotone
category of metric spaces you find the
work of love vir which essentially in
this paper from 64 chose unpublished
Indian he was defining the Chrysler
category for what we call later giri
mana then we have of course the giri
mana do we know about it and here in
this work appears the concept of polish
spaces as being a central one we also
know from people which are looking to
the logical characterization of by
simulation that the having a polished
space there is essential to talk to to
guarantee that the logical the logical
characterization really characterizes by
simulation so the logic really
characterizes by simulation so in
general probabilistic reasons reasoning
is based on measure theory but it works
better if you have a metric if you have
a Polish space there so means to have a
complete separable metric space behind
so we are not only looking to monads for
category of metric spaces but also for
Mon arts category of complete separable
metric space so I'm gonna show you all
these metrics are appear in relation
with semantics since the beginning so
the entire school of Yokota Becker was
doing that so the goal of this work is
like this to try to develop a theory of
effects on metric settings so I'm trying
to look to monitor on the on the on the
category of metric spaces I'm trying to
define a concept of algebra that is
coming also if a metric structure and
then define a quantitative equational
they worry about this so I'm gonna make
immediately all this clear and all I'm
doing here I'm trying to do it and to
essentially mimic what beer coffe that
what what big bit of did for universal
algebra so I I aim to arrive to become
kind of theorems to prove completeness
theorem so all the kind of
results that we have for universal
algebra so let's start with an example
just to understand better how the
classic equation or theory works and
what we have to generalize here so I'm
going to introduce four V's barycentric
algebras which will appear a lot in this
talk it was introduced by stone in 14 I
maybe even before him but that's the
worldís reference I found so essentially
a biocentric algebra is a universal
algebra which has a signature a plus
index it with epsilon is a binary
operator epsilon can be between 0 & 1
and satisfy these axioms so to
understand exactly let's take a model of
it and we will see exactly this axiom
say so if we take for instance a
measurable space and if they are looking
to either the probabilistic
distributions finish support or the
general probability distribution over
this measurable space and we interpret
plus epsilon like multiplying the first
metric live action with the second one
with 1 minus Epsilon we can have an
interpretation of these axioms and we
see that the first one says that plus 1
T plus 1 T prime is exactly T plus
epsilon T plus epsilon T is exactly T
this is called the skew commutativity so
here notice that epsilon became on this
side 1 minus epsilon obviously and this
is the skew associativity this is a bit
more complicated but you understand
exactly why we have to work with this
linear combinations so this is a
polycentric algebra yes you can all on
this or on this define such an algebra
and they satisfy this axioms we're going
to discuss actually about all these
spaces a bit later so that's why I
introduced them already but Sigma is the
Sigma algebra this is a certain this is
the Sigma T over that set and this is
the set of problems in distribution over
this seem algebra
no you don't yeah
second one does it includes the first
one yeah yes it does you don't need to
know but we will discuss both of them
you will see immediately when we go from
metric space it complete separable
metric spaces that we can use one as
approximation of the other we will
aright there anyway this is just
universal algebra so what is such a such
a theory defines it defines the
Congressional it's a relation over terms
this is what we are equating by that
equation all Tory so if you go to the
meta-level we will have some met axioms
now I'm also using the whole closes
because I want the tower including whole
process so I will have a rule of
reflexivity which is not stated there
but obviously exist which says from no
hypothesis I can prove T equal T I have
a symmetry and I have transitivity as
basic rules and of course of all the
functions in the signature Omega must so
the equality must be a congruence so
these are axioms that we are we are
assuming anyway for all all this kind of
universal algebra so when we are giving
the maximization so now to achieve what
I want I want to move from defining
congruence on terms equational ii to
define absurdo metric or a uniformity on
terms how do I do that
instead of having the equation of top
type X s equal T I'm going to have a
question of type s equal epsilon T which
will mean that s and T are in distance
epsilon to each other so if I do that
I will still have the reflectivity I
will still have the symmetry but of
course I'm not going to have
transitivity so the transitivity will be
now replaced by triangle inequality so
if s is a distance epsilon of T the
distance Delta of U s and here sorry
should be you yes Anu will be a distance
epsilon plus Delta so this is already a
still in 0 1 for instance if we speak
about
in fact in this work we want it to be
just any number I want I said
metric spaces but I want actually
unbounded metric space metric spaces
because if I cannot define an equation
between two terms I'm expecting those
two terms to be a distance plus infinite
and I want to allow that to happen and
in fact to prove later the Bidco theorem
I need to be sure that my categories
close to arbitrary products and that
will only happen if I allow this
extended metric spaces and not just
metric spaces okay and what else the
congruence rule itself must be replaced
with something and in this so this
presentation is based on our leaks paper
and in that paper we actually propose to
replace the congruence pond condition
with one non expansiveness condition so
if all the terms si are distance epsilon
of Ti then putting them inside the
function I will still be epsilon here
somebody can say well this is a kind of
ad hoc decision I agree you can change
it you can put here Lipschitz condition
whatever you like the Towery can still
go on but in our paper we do this
because we think that this category is
quite nice the category of metric spaces
with non expansive maps as more feasible
okay so I replace this then I would have
a few other axioms like Max says that if
SN EPS and TR the distance epsilon they
must be a distance epsilon plus Delta
for whatever Delta so I can max if I can
argue about that then I have necessarily
an Archimedean rule which says for
whatever epsilon if I can prove that s
is that at least distance Delta from T
for any Delta strictly bigger than
epsilon then it must be also distance
epsilon this is obviously infinitary so
here I'm going to have premises in our
paper actually we are only speaking
about this in this is being rational and
the Tory works fine but it's not a
necessary condition here but it works
for for nice for rational if you have a
rational here you can still produce
rational theories but in the case of
barycentric algebra already plus e it
was defined for octave
so I already have an uncountable
signature so staying under countability
conditions doesn't make much sense but
it can be done okay and then of course I
have to have substitution rule cut
assumptions of the classic things and
this will be what we will call a
quantitative the disability relation and
you see how it appears from taking the
classic the disability relation and
arguing about how to exchange equal with
equal Epsilon
okay so now what is the quantitative
equational theory I'm starting with a
signature Omega ascetics of variables
I'm going to construct the terms then a
quantitative equation will be an
equation of this type where STR terms
and epsilon is 0 1 here for instance and
a quantitative inference is an inference
of this type I have a set of hypothesis
let's say and they will prove on an
equation and now a quantitative
equational Theory will be just a set of
such inferences that is closed under the
disability met axioms that I just showed
you so this is the definition of a
quantitative equation of Tory
okay what is the quantitative algebra
the conductive algebra is just a uniform
is just a universal algebra it just oh
no mega algebra which in addition has
also metric structure ad symmetric space
and all functions in the signature are
non expansive with respect to the metric
structure what is amorphous a morphism
of such quantitative algebra is just the
map which first of all is a omega
homomorphism and second of all is also
non expansive if we look to the matrix
structure
okay so now let's see what is the
semantics when can I say that an algebra
satisfies an inference so suppose that I
have a quantitative algebra of this type
in the set X of variables I will define
an assignment just being an Omega
homomorphism which interprets all the
terms in te TX as elements in a being a
homo murphy's here warranties that can
be defined from any map from X to a can
be lifted so this is just syntactic
sugar so now I'm going to say that such
an algebra satisfies an inference of
this type
so this says if si equal epsilon y TI
for all I then I can prove s equal
epsilon T so I I would say that such an
algebra satisfy this inference if for
any assignment if I have that the
distance between the interpretation of
Si on an interpretation of TI is always
small or equal to epsilon I for all I
this will imply that the distance
between the interpretation as an
interpretation of T smaller or equal to
Epsilon so the expected definition so
this is what we will write like like
this so a satisfy this okay so now we
know when an algebra satisfies an
equation let's speak about completeness
so given a signature giving a set of
variables and the quantitative
equational theory you define on these
variables I will denote by K Omega u so
I emphasize the signature and the theory
the set of all quantitative algebra
satisfying you so this is what in the
classic case is if you don't have work
laid closest is a variety if you have
foreign corn closest the quasi variety
so the first theorem says that such an
inference easy new if and only if any
algebra in this class satisfies it so we
have the completeness
okay now let's speak about term algebras
because we want to arrive to Mona's so
I'm starting from a signature a set of
variables I'm constructing the terms
then given a quantitative equational
theory I have now to construct absurdo
metric over terms because i want to turn
the algebra of terms at this moment I
already have an Omega algebra right we
know this but now I want to have a
quantitative algebra so I need to define
absurdo metric on terms that will
reflect what the equation of Tori tells
me so I'm going to define such episode o
matic I call it bu how I would say that
the distance between s and T is the
infimum of all e with the property that
from no hypothesis I can prove that s
equal epsilon T is in you and in fact
it's not difficult to see that this is
the same thing we're saying that for any
set of hypothesis I'd this is still in
the theory so this is absurd Oh metric
but I need a metric to define the metric
space the the metric space we define the
quantitative algebra so I'm going to
take the quotient on the kernel of D U
and I'm gonna get a metric space over
the equivalence classes so this I call
it now with square bracket six okay so
the first theorem we have now is that
this is indeed a quantitative algebra
not only but it's satisfying indeed the
theory you which you use for
constructing it okay so we construct the
term algebra but we want now to generate
models from arbitrary sets in fact this
construction has three steps first I'm
going to generate models from arbitrary
sets that I'm going to then I'm going to
generate models from metric spaces and
then I'm going to generate models from
complete separable metric spaces and we
will do all this free construction on
top of each other so starting with set
suppose that I have such a theory define
on T X Omega in the set M then I first
of all I can construct all the terms
from M and then I have to define a
parametric accumulate as in the case of
DX because in the case of
I was using the fact that the elements
of TX are already appearing in the
equations but in the equations here of
you I have nothing about em so now I
have to use the assignments so I define
absurdo metric on p.m. as being the
supreme for all geometrics I can define
on TM such that all the assignments are
on expansive so this will be the final
shadow metric for the corner assignments
to TM if you want to know if such a
thing exists but it has an alternative a
dual characterization which is nice and
it's more in the sense of proof systems
so this distance will be the infimum of
all the values such that exist two terms
st in TX and an assignment that
interprets these two terms as mr n
respectively and moreover as equal ET is
in the theory so i can somehow prove the
thing about m 1 and this is what it says
so I'm gonna take the infimum of all
that this is not zelda metric and again
i'm gonna take its kernel to get a
metric and now i can prove the first
thing i prove here is that doing this
construction for the case in which M is
exactly X will give me exactly what I
construct for X so first of all these
two metric spaces are ISO ISO metric and
in fact the automatic I'm constructing
it in this way for m equal to X is the
same thing which the one I call started
before directly for X and the important
theorem is that first of all this
algebra that I'm quantitative algebra
that I'm constructing in this way indeed
satisfy my theory and it has the
universality property so TM has the
universal metal property from M to the
forgetful factor that map's any
quantitative algebra to its support set
so this mean that for whatever mapping
from the set m to a set a exists a
unique morphus of quantitative algebra
from TM to the quantitative algebra
ported by that set such that this
diagram here commute so this what will
give me immediately is that the
essential defines a monad on set this is
not what I wanted I wanted the Mona
don't met but already this construction
gives me an interesting example and this
is the first example I will give you the
left invariant barycentric algebra so I
take the barycentric algebraic showed
you before and I add to it this axiom I
call it left invariant l I T prime plus
CT equal if t ii + ET for any epsilon
bigger or equal to VD or you can imagine
here if you don't have rational this can
be exactly okay so why is this
interesting so this is an axiomatization
and i'm claiming that is like tsumetai
single metric let's see what metric is
this axiom attacking let's call this
theory you li from left invariant so
here is a model for that theory
I keep here only Li you will see
immediately why is sound for this model
and you will get it okay so I'm taking a
set m and I'm looking toward the Phoenix
supported probability distributions on
it and I'm gonna interpret plus e as
before take the total variation distance
which is defined as two premium for all
in M of this this can be defined for
general metrics in fact and the theorem
says that if I'm taking this algebra
with this signature and with total
variation distance as a metric this
actually satisfy you alike and now you
can see why L is sound here and you'll
have the intuition because when I break
into what this means I will get this and
this difference is always smaller could
be one okay so and this is not the
important theory but the important
theorem is this I was able to prove that
the term algebra constructed as before
is in fact isometric with it's in fact
isomorphic with this one and isomorphism
is the one associating to each element
of M the Dirac measure on M
you - ro you - new yeah it must be ro
here sorry yeah you're right
so what does this mean this means that
this algebra is actually the one freely
generated so this means that my
axiomatization including this is
actually axiom wising the total
variation distance so here is a first
argument of why believing the total
variation distance is a kind of
canonical distance in this context and
here still the mana DS on set but let's
go further and constrain monotone met so
now suppose that I have such a theory
and I have a metric space MD and I want
to use this as a generator so what I do
first of all I'm gonna take all the
elements in them and add them as
constants in my signature so now my
signature would be this one
I'm gonna take my tell you and I'm gonna
add to it all the axioms of type M equal
epsilon and now M and n are constants
from M
and I'm gonna add this axiom if this
happens and I'm gonna call now this
theory um so I'm putting it together you
I prove everything I can and that's um
now I can construct this before the
algebra but I'm gonna construct it for
the empty set
but I'm constructing it for the tower um
and for the signature Omega M so now
what I get I have also a forgetful
founder from the category of this
algebra to the category of this algebras
what is happening exactly I take an
algebraic forget about the constants so
I'm going to get an algebra there right
and now I'm going to call T DM which is
what I'm going to obtain as an algebra
in this category once I'm forgetting the
interpretation of the constants and this
is now of course in this category so
this is how I'm constructing
quantitative algebra generated by M
starting from a metric space and this
one with respect to the one I construct
before
also takes into account the natural
distances between the elements of the
generators okay so the first term says
that this is indeed an algebra there and
the second theorem says that this
algebra has in fact the universal
mapping property for thematic space M D
to the forgetful factor which takes the
quantitative algebra and forgets the
algebraic structure and these define our
monotone met so now we arrived -
monotone on metric space on the category
of metric spaces okay
before going to two major examples here
I want to go to the next level and also
see what's happening if I'm starting
from a complete separable metric space
as a generator so if I have a
quantitative algebra of this type I'm
going to call its completeness a
quantitative algebra which has this
property that a bar b bar is the
completeness in the metric sense of the
metric space ad so I'm taking the metric
space C D which might be not complete
I'm completing it adding all the limits
of Cauchy sequences this is a bar b bar
so and this will give me this algebra
how do I make it an algebra all the
operators in the signature I'm going to
have that F in this algebra when I'm
taking a limit will be the result of
taking to the limit of the components so
if I'm doing that I will get an algebra
now which has a support of complete
metric space I'm going to call
continuous equation well skim any
inference such that the value of equal
here is a continuous function in these
values here of course for having this
working guy I'm I need to have only
inferences we've seen a set of
hypotheses and an important theorem says
that if a quantitative algebra satisfies
a continuous equation skin of this type
then its completion satisfies it as well
so this is the kind of things which the
process of completing will guarantee to
preserve okay and this theorem says like
this if I'm starting with a quantitative
equation or theory which can be
actualized by continuous equational
schemes an MD is a metric space then
this 12 algebras are isomorphic which is
the one the one I can construct for the
completeness of the metric space is
isomorphic with the completion of the
one I can construct from the metric
space I'm starting with so these two are
item
this is an important result and you'll
see it immediately used so now let's
take some example the first important
example is the one we call the
interpolated barycentric algebra so
again I have the barycentric algebras
with these axioms q associativity skew
to commutativity and symmetry and so on
any in addition I have this special
axiom which says if s1 is a distance
epsilon 1 of T 1 s 2 this distance
epsilon 2 of T 2 then s 1 plus e is 2 is
a distance delta T 1 plus C 2 where
Delta is just the composing these two
things and using P so let's call this
new P and in fact what is in four four
four four an is intuition if P is equal
to 1 Delta is just the linear
combination of you wanna need to using
this e buzz factor and the intuition is
this for for P equal 1 if s 1 and T 1
are at this distance s 2 and T 2 are at
this distance here from beyond s 2 then
s 1 plus e is 2 so he represent this
presented here this is exactly the same
so this is just a geometrical factor so
this this axiom here I be in this
indexed by P here and here I gave you
the intuition for P equal 1 speaks about
convexity speaks about how convex sets
should be constructed so bigger or equal
this is P Vasher Stein I'm going to
prove immediately I'm going to prove
that this axiomatization axiom you ties
be faster Stein and for P equal 1 axiom
or ties kantorovich
okay so let's start from a metric space
let's be PI of M be definitively support
the probability measures on M and define
plus e as before
this is the peevish our style metric is
defined in this way where here Omega is
taking us from the set of coupling so
I'm grateful to Frank that he already
introduced you to couplings what is
important is that for P equal 1 we get
exactly the contour of each distance of
which Frank just told you about ok so
what is happening now the first theorem
says that if I'm constructing the
algebra PI M index by P here depends on
which axiom I'm using this actually
satisfies the telling you P in
particular PI 1 satisfies the w1 and
moreover this one is exactly the freely
generated one and the way I can prove it
prove this isomer you know again I'm
going to associate to each element here
the Dirac distribution there and then
extend so this it will give so this
construction so this says that this
algebra is the freely generated one from
my axioms from my by towering ok I'm not
happy because it's we've seen Utley
supported so I want to go further reason
for which I will first notice that the
theory is axiom you ties by continuous
equation of schemes because this is
continuous this Delta is a continuous
function in epsilon 1 epsilon 2 here ok
so I'm going to use the term I showed
you before to go to what I call
continuous case so now I'm starting with
a complete separable metric space so I'm
not constructing from ethics with work
from complete separable metric spaces so
I'm in a Polish space now let Delta M be
the boreal probabilistic measures on him
all of them
so I know that on Delta Remi exists the
so called weak topology which is the
topology having this property that for a
sequence of measures converge to that
measure given that for all bounded
continuous functions f from M to R we
have this integral converge lebesgue
integral and there is this theory of
this theorem you find it for instance in
villanies book which says that if md is
a complete separable a complete and
separable then PI of M which is the one
of probability probabilities we finished
support is dense in Delta of M in this
weak topology and moreover for all piece
the vash the peevish time distance
matrices the weak topology so I'm going
to use now this term so I know I prove
already that the freely generated model
is isomorphic with one I get from
probabilities within a support I'm going
to complete now this one so this base
since MD is complete inseparable it's
easy to prove it is separable but it's
not necessarily complete so I'm going to
complete it now let's say that this is
its completion complete in matrix sense
then this theorem says like this if MD
is complete and separable then the
algebra of all distributions with a
certain distance is isomorphic wave the
algebra I can get freely generated from
the completion of this space which is
again isomorphic with the algebra I get
by completing the algebra can construct
it from my metric space an imparticular
the completion of PI M is Delta M so the
completion of the space of probability
is a finished support is the space of
all probabilities
and this happens for all P of course I
will change the axiom and this mean that
also for contour which is happening so
this means that the axioms I showed you
axiom you ties P Vassar Stein induction
Matas kantorovich and remember what this
axiom was all about it speaks about
convexity so contour which derives
canonically naturally from a concept of
convexity and not from anything else
this is an argument for its canonicity
okay we are already in we are already
hoping to prove a similar result for the
unbounded case in the case of contour of
each function might must be bounded and
apparently from our search nobody looked
to the unbounded case because in general
people are not interested in metric
spaces an unbounded metric spaces for us
for us in metric space can have the
value plus infinite we need that because
we need our category to be close to
arbitrary products to get a variety okay
let me give you a second example I think
not sure if is if I mean what is
important here is the theorem which says
that P Vassar Stein axiom you Tice's the
matrices the the wake topology and that
result is not mine is a classic result
so I have seen the proof for that I
don't know if it's true if P is more
equal one I don't know because you marry
me
curious what happens there yeah I would
be curious to I don't know this is
already on the list of our future work
because we want to understand more about
the this also about the the duality
behind what is called control of each
duality but for the vast stein case so
there are some open questions there so
here's another example I'm taking a
signature which is the signature of semi
lattices with zero I have plus on 0 I
have these axioms observe that all of
them are equal zero so are the just semi
lattices plus this one which says if s1
is this distance epsilon 1 of T 1 s 2
epsilon 2 of T 2 the next one plus s2 is
a distance maximum between epsilon 1
epsilon 2 of T 1 and T 2 so to not late
to wait this axiom entices hausdorff
metric induced by D so I'm going to
prove it to you immediately and look
here what does give us house door where
is house door coming from ok so let's
start with a metric space md let F of M
be the set of all finite subsets of M I
will interpret plus as Union and zero is
the empty set the first theorem says
that this algebra now indeed satisfy the
axioms I just showed you
let's take a look back so also this one
okay we're HD here is the house-door
metric induced by D so on moreover this
algebra is actually isomorphic with the
freely generated one and isomorphism is
given by associated to each element M
the single tone M is the finitary case
it's one I want to go to the to the
infinite case to the continuous case for
that I'm starting now is a complete
separable metric space and now let GM be
the set of all closed subsets of M if
I'm not working with matrix that must
have only values smaller than plus
infinite I can define now hausdorff
directly on closed sets I don't need to
reduce myself to the compact sets so now
let's GMB the set of all closed sets on
em I know already that FM is isomorphic
with the algebra fraternity by M and E
is separable this guarantees that this
is separable too but not necessarily
complete that's before so let's complete
it let's say this is its completion then
this theorem says that the completion of
this space is isomorphic actually with
the space of all closed subsets with the
signature with house daughter and in
fact GM is the completion of FM so here
is the proof that the axioms I just
showed you
Exuma ties house door
so these are two examples there are
other examples many actually that we
work and we are continue working you can
speak about su probability distribution
by simply adding a constant to the
signature of body centric algebra which
will be the sink we have a concept of
monoidal barycentric algebra so it's a
very centric algebra of the structure of
mu no you don't top and we get the trace
based matrix for Markov chains and
markov processes and many other cases
that our students are working on let me
say a bit about the related work so
Frank and the others in 2007 have
already given an equation all but in the
ordinary sense presentation of housed
often contour of each and exhibits
monads of the category of complete
separable metric spaces but is the
classic way and they use the the mean
valued algebra and some inequalities as
well in the equation or part but not
this kind of approximated equations the
anatomy can all show the finitary nature
of these monads then there is some work
of yeah kobzon or from 2015 that we are
still trying to understand how they are
related to this work but since none of
us really understood it let's say that
should be there so they speak about the
effectors instead of affect I cannot
tell you more about that but for future
work we have a long list most of the
work I showed you about posture stand
and contour of each works obvious it's
sorry except watch the sign-in contour
which works in in in matrix that can
have value plus infinite not this too
and this is because the work in in in
the field of major theory did not look
at least this is what we believe did not
look to that we did not find any
reference in in any book so we need to
extend also the kantorovich rubenstein
duality which is essentially improving
what I just showed you for busting in
contour which to this kind of resource
so we are looking to
- those proof to see if they can be done
what you just asked about P being
smaller of one could be also fit here
maybe it works as well I don't know it
is still a mystery for now what should
be the right metric for Markov processes
which by similarity matrix I showed you
that we discover if you speak about
trace matrix but by similarity because
it involved a fixed point computation
fixed point seems to be a kind of
completion of some space we are still
thinking about this seems to need to me
that we need at least some many sorted
version of this entire story we are
working to prove the similar a bit off
theory might succeed already to prove
that if I'm in a case of equational
theory without horn closes then I can
define a concept of quasi conceptive
variety so closed under homomorphic
images products and soup algebras that's
sufficient to characterize when a class
of such algebras can be oxidized in the
case of having horn closes the
conjecture is that we need
indeed the concept of quasi for it
should be closed under some directed
products and isomorphism and sub
algebras but we didn't complete that
proof the big deal here is that
ultimately we can speak about this
quantitative algebra in terms of first
order structures you would think because
if you can think about each equal
epsilon as being a binary relation but
the problem is that having behind
relation between this equal epsilon for
instance if something is the distance
equal epsilon is also distance equal to
epsilon plus delta-t media roots and so
on you realize that actually you are not
in first order but you are in second
order structure so everything became
messy if you want to do classic model
theory on it so I'm trying various kind
of things it's not clear if this will be
resolved soon and anyway we have many
applications in mind essentially we want
to propose the community to start
thinking about metric semantics for for
quantitative programming languages in
which we are not only thinking about
equivalences because they are
meaningless in a certain sense but we
want to think about
if not numbers necessarily at least
apologies so this is more or less what
they want you to say questions instead
of questions right they will give a
discussion section will find reading the
discussion